guten morgen stefan und herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren im
reichstagsgebäude im deutschen bundestag
wo es heute ein recht langer tag wird
für die abgeordneten aber auch für uns
wir sind bis mindestens 20 uhr dabei
wenn es nötig wird auch ein klein wenig
länger und es gibt viele wichtige
tagesordnungspunkte heute beispielsweise
kurz nach 9 der entwicklungspolitische
bericht der bundesregierung dann wird es
gehen um den internationalen frauentag
und das wird gehen um zwei un missionen
an der die bundesliga in denen die
bundeswehr beteiligt ist nämlich
bewaffnete missionen sogar einmal im
südsudan und auf der anderen seite auch
im mittelmeer und es wird dann am
späteren abend gehen um die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht da gibt es anträge
aus der afg und auch aus der
unionsfraktion und um den sogenannten
genesenen status so lange müssen sie
natürlich nicht warten wir besprechen
das thema nämlich jetzt schon gleich und
ich freue mich dass da ist heike behrens
die gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der
spd-fraktion und die größe herzlich kino
sorge aus der unionsfraktion auch da ist
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher wir
werden natürlich nicht umhinkommen einen
blick zu werfen auf die beschlüsse die
gestern in der bund länder runde gefasst
worden sind es soll lockerungen geben
das haben wir eben im beitrag man auch
schon gesehen welche punkt ist da um
welche punkte ist im einzelnen geht aber
gucken wir vielleicht noch mal auf ihre
persönliche bewertung dieser beschlüsse
gestern frau behrens was ist ihre
einschätzung ja erstmal ist ja klasse
dass das was die modellierer
vorhergesagt haben nämlich das mitte
februar im grunde der höhepunkt der
pandemie wohl erreicht sein wird dass
sich das erfüllt hat und wir jetzt
einfach die chance haben auch erst
eröffnungs schritte zu machen und ich
finde da ist gestern maßvoll entschieden
worden indem man eben diese drei stufen
sich vorgenommen hat ich glaube das ist
verantwortbar was da beschlossen worden
ist muss man glaube ich sagen die
pandemie bezüglich bezogen auf die
omikron welle nämlich wie das im laufe
des jahres weiter geht kann kann auch
der beste modell ihrer im moment nicht
vorhersagen herr sorge was ist ihre
einschätzung der beschlüsse von gestern
also mein eindruck ist auch dass das in
die richtige richtung geht ich hätte mir
zwar gewünscht dass wir über öffnungs
schritte auch über konkrete dinge schon
viel früher gesprochen wir müssen jetzt
schauen dass eben auch die relativ
geäußerten dinge in diesem beschluss
dann auch umgesetzt werden sie haben sie
angesprochen das thema genießen den
status ist noch offen das thema
einrichtungs bezogen im pflicht ist noch
offen und vor allen dingen das
kommunikationsdesaster was wir hatten
mit dem rk ii das müsse auch geklärt
werden und die impfpflicht die
allgemeine sondern und ich besprochen da
können wir aber gleich noch mal drauf
ich wollte noch mal gucken ob das was
gestern beschlossen worden ist biologen
und mediziner sagen es ist ein bisschen
gewagt so konkrete zahlen auch zu setzen
weil egal wie präzise die modellierer
bislang auch gewesen sind sie haben es
ja eben gesagt wirklich wissen tut man
nicht wie die lage im am zwanzigsten
märz ist ja ich glaube wir müssen jetzt
sorgsam darauf achten dass dieses
frühlings erwachen was wir jetzt
sozusagen ein bisschen in turnieren dass
das nicht zu einem bösen erwachen wird
und das erfordert eben wirklich dass
alle miteinander weiter sehr aufmerksam
sind wir in der politik müssen sehr
sorgsam beobachten wie es jetzt
tatsächlich die weitere infektions lage
wie ist die entwicklung in unseren
krankenhäusern vor allem wir wissen auch
noch nicht ob die mikrowelle nicht erst
noch bei den älteren in der bevölkerung
ankommt das würde natürlich noch mal
echte rückschläge bedeuten das muss
alles sehr sorgsam beobachtet werk und
ich glaube die botschaft von gestern
muss auch sein dass alle bürgerinnen und
bürger weiter sehr aufmerksam sein
müssen also kontakte weiterhin begrenzt
halten masken tragen nur immer möglich
die abstandsgebot einhalten das
erfordert schon weiter ziemlich viel
disziplin von uns ein ist die frage ob
das die versorger überhaupt noch
funktioniert nach den beschlüssen von
gestern denn die signale werden ja
größtenteils dann so gewertet werden wir
sind über den berg also muss ich auch
nicht mehr so aufpassen sie haben gesagt
man hätte die öffnungs debatte sogar
schon viel früher führen müssen auch
dass es nicht so ganz allgemeiner
konsens sondern kommt aus einzelnen
einrichtungen immer was denken sie wie
riskant ist es jetzt nach diesen
beschlüssen oder wie fahrlässig wenn die
leute jetzt sein der kunde muss man ja
froh sein dass diese panik prognosen die
ja auch von bundesgesundheitsminister in
den letzten wochen immer wieder erzeugt
wurden sind sich so nicht bewahrheitet
haben und deshalb glaube ich ist es
jetzt ganz wichtig mit einer gewissen
vorlaufzeit auch zu sagen ja wir können
optimistisch in die zukunft gehen wir
können auch öffnungen wagen aber wir
müssen jetzt grundsätzlich die debatte
führen was nach dem 19 märz passiert
weil alle maßnahmen auch die grundlage
der maßnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz würden dann
auslaufen ist sei denn der bundestag
verlängert diese grundlage und da müssen
wir jetzt auch sehr grundsätzlich
sprechen weil selbst in der
ampelkoalition fdp beispielsweise ja
sagt wir brauchen diese maßnahmen
eigentlich gar nicht mehr und ich bin
immer der meinung dass wir eher
begründen müssen warum maßnahmen noch in
kraft sein sollen anstatt zu sagen das
ist halt irgendwie moderat ist als
ziemlich bequem dass man diese grundlage
hat sondern die bundesregierung das ist
ja auch in diesem beschluss klar
geworden ist jetzt aufgefordert
entsprechend neuregelung foto zu sehen
wie es nach dem 19 weitergehen soll und
das erwartet das habe ich nicht
verstanden was sie denn eigentlich
wollen sie haben von panik prognosen ihm
zu sagen man mit karl lauterbach
gesprochen er hat aber mit seiner
prognose eigentlich recht gehabt relativ
präzise sogar was auch was die tage
angeht nämlich dass die mikrowelle jetzt
gebrochen ist an dieser stelle was ich
war jetzt in aus ihrer antwort licht aus
gehört haben wollen sie jetzt dass
bestimmte instrumente weiter bestehen
auch über den zwanzigsten märz hinaus
müsste dann im infektionsschutzgesetz
werden oder sagen sie es kann jetzt noch
euch alles weg da müssen sie sich jetzt
mal festlegen bei der eine punkt ist
dass das was jetzt passiert ja kein
geheimnis war das waren die modellierung
von einem experten die gesagt haben
omikron ganz neue rahmenbedingungen
viele milde verläuft aber auch sehr
viele neue infektionen und gleichzeitig
ab mitte februar ein sehr starkes
abflachen an dieser kurve und da hätte
ich mir gewünscht dass wir auch die
aufforderung auch aus den ländern schon
viel früher diese öffnung szenarien
durchzuspielen wir haben die diskussion
momentan im handel wir haben die
diskussion in der gastronomie die sagen
das kommt jetzt zum richtigen zeitpunkt
aber teilweise eben noch gefällig
unkonkret und deshalb noch mal der punkt
auch der frage der öffnung also
maßnahmen müssen die formen das müssen
wir jetzt führen die debatte und dazu
muss wahrscheinlich auch neue
gesetzliche regelung jetzt muss ich ihn
nochmals entschuldigen sie kommen gleich
doppelt deswegen weil er mir das nicht
beantwortet hat was soll was sollte drin
sein in diesen vielzitierten
instrumentenkasten nach dem zwanzigsten
märz im infektionsschutzgesetz ihrer
meinung nach das muss eine grundlage für
die länder geben konnte so kommt er aus
reinem eine art basisschutz also dass
die länder die möglichkeit haben sofern
gefährliche varianten auftreten sollten
schnell wieder zu reagieren dann ist die
frage ob wir diesen instrumenten kassen
so wie er momentan auch unter delta
gesichtspunkten auf den weg gebracht
worden ist in der form brauchen
nachjustieren müssen und das ist ja auch
in den beschluss aufgeführt das also
begrüßte dass die bundesregierung jetzt
dabei ist auch diese überarbeitung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auf den weg zu
bringen und das werden wir im märz dann
im plenum entsprechend auf debattieren
müssen dass ich mal gucken ob ich sie
konkret zu konkreteren aussagen kriege
frau während er hat ja nur basisschutz
gesagt das ist was die meisten unter
masken verstehen beziehungsweise die
meisten verstehen nur massen darunter
andere sagen zum basisschutz gehört auch
ich glaube franziska giffey hat sich
gestern abend gestern am späten
nachmittag ähnlich geäußert gehören auch
tests beispielsweise
und die ausstandspflicht und und
tatsächlich auch kontakt beschränkungen
was ist ihre sicht ja also die
regelungen die wir im 28 absatz 7 bisher
haben das
infektionsschutzgesetz genau das sind im
grunde diese basis schutzmaßnahmen die
auch die länder jetzt zu recht erneut
einfordern sie sagen wir brauchen weiter
dieses instrumentarium um dort wo es
gegebenenfalls um besonderes
ausbruchsgeschehen gibt um dort auch
reagieren zu können und ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass das richtig ist
denn es sind möglichkeiten da werden
optionen zur verfügung gestellt die die
länder je nach bedarf tatsächlich
greifen können oder eben auch nicht
greifen können das ist angemessenes
handeln in der pandemie dieses brauchen
wir und dazu müssen wir so hat herr
sorge schon recht dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz ändern aber ich
will schon noch einen aspekt anfügen da
ist nicht nur die koalition gebracht sie
haben mal gesagt sie wollen eine
konstruktive opposition sein und beim
infektionsschutzgesetz geht es schon
darum die voraussetzungen zu schaffen
dass die bundesländer handlungsfähig
sind und das ist eine sollte eine
gemeinsame verantwortung dieses
parlamentes sein und vor allem auch im
zusammenwirken wirklich von bund und
ländern da hat er ja nicht wenige unions
ministerpräsidenten im nacken der wird
er so viele möglichkeiten glaube ich
dann gar nicht haben auch hier im
bundestag aber ich will konsum auf den
hauptpunkten ordentlich läuft ja auf dem
punkt kommen wie sie eben angesprochen
haben das was sie gesagt haben was sind
was noch nötig sein wird fordern auch
die grünen ich habe irene mihalic im
laufe der woche dazu gesehen gelesen und
gehört die fdp sieht das ein klein wenig
anders christian buer hat beispielsweise
am dienstag vor der fraktionssitzung
gesagt im grunde müssen wir alles erst
mal streichen weil wir handlungsfähig
sind und notfalls schnell auch bestimmte
sachen wieder installieren können also
wie viel diskussionen wird es an dieser
stelle wenn der koalition dazu noch
geben dazu gibt es mit sicherheit
intensive diskussion und umso wichtiger
war es dass gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gemeinsam
mit dem bundeskanzler hier klar diese
punkte eingefordert haben das wird uns
wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen
rückenwind geben auch in den beratungen
mit der fdp und ich will an der stelle
durchaus auch ein bisschen deutlicher
werden ich erwarte tatsächlich hier von
dem kleinsten koalitionspartner auch
dass er sich wirklich in das gemeinsame
anliegen der pandemie bekämpfung und
pandemie bewältigung stellt und dazu
gehört es auch dass man den ländern das
notwendige instrumentarium zur verfügung
stellt damit sie die schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen können die gegebenenfalls
notwendig sind denn es ist tatsächlich
es werden möglichkeiten zur verfügung
gestellt und nicht dinge festgeschrieben
die bekämpfung der pandemie ist
weiterhin das stichwort herr sorge wird
es eine allgemeine impfpflicht geben in
absehbarer zeit da die haben halt sich
dafür wir haben als union einen antrag
unterbreiten kann ich meine frage die
frage sind sie für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht weil ich will sehen ja
gerade erklären wir haben diesen antrag
eben deshalb auch unterbreitet weil wir
sehen dass es ein sehr breites
meinungsspektrum gibt bei der frage
allgemeine helmpflicht ist ja schon
fraglich was heißt denn allgemeine
impfpflicht und deshalb haben wir gesagt
wir brauchen eine impfpflicht für den
fall gefährlicher varianten ich halte es
für falsch zu sagen wir beschließen eine
impfpflicht für alle auf vorrat für eine
variante die wir nicht kennen mit
impfstoffen die im herbst überhaupt noch
nicht absehbar sind und zum schluss
gruppen nicht definieren wo wir wissen
da gibt es eine statistisch hohes risiko
und es hat den sehr ausgewogenen entwurf
vorgelegt und sind also nicht d'accord
mit dem antrag so alle einfach mal
pauschal impfen lassen zu wollen wir
müssen sprache präzise sein dass die
union vorgelegt hat ist ein antrag das
was diverse gruppen vorlegen werden und
wo er jetzt auch die die gruppe um ein
büro ullmann was vorgelegten
gesetzentwürfe ich habe schon gesehen
sie sind gar nicht einverstanden mit dem
was er gerade gesagt hat nein es ist ja
leider auch sehr missverständlich was er
vorträgt weil die union hat ihren antrag
überschrieben mit dem vorsorge wer aber
im vorsorge betreiben will der muss
jetzt im grunde den schritt gehen damit
im herbst vorgesorgt ist das heißt denn
wir haben nun
ein herr sorge wir haben die situation
dass ein ganz so gut zu dem wesen und
dann
von anfang bis ende gewesen und sie habe
diese darauf eingeht wer wer im herbst
einen immunschutz haben möchte der muss
im grunde das impfschema durchlaufen
haben und das sind eben nach heutigem
wissensstand drei impfungen und für
diese drei impfungen braucht man vier
monate das heißt wenn wir im herbst
geimpft ankommen wollen dann müssen wir
die menschen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
auffordern lasst euch impfen damit wir
echte vorsorge betreiben können und das
ist doch unser anliegen wir wollen kein
wir wollen vor die nächste welle kommen
wir wollen verhindern dass wenn wir
durch irgendeine virusvariante wieder
überrascht werden dass wir wirklich den
immunschutz innerhalb der bevölkerung
auf einem stand haben die bösen menschen
nicht mehr schwer und wo eben auch
todesfälle verhindert werden und wer
vorsorge treiben möchte der sollte sich
jetzt dafür einsetzen eine impfpflicht
für alle erwachsenen wirklich
voranzutreiben und im übrigen herr sorge
ich glaube wir hätten an farbpunkten
durchaus anknüpfungspunkte zwischen
ihrem antrag und unseren gesetzentwurf
und darüber sollten wir dann vielleicht
in kürze mal ins gespräch kommen damit
wir am ende eine breite mehrheit für
echte vorsorge in der pandemie bekommen
gerne direkt rationen also lebensmittel
frau kollegin dass das ganze ein
bisschen ein politisches kabarett also
jetzt zu sagen in dem moment wo sie
mitbekommen sie bekommen keine mehrheit
nicht mal innerhalb der eigenen
koalition haben sie eine mehrheit für
den antrag zu einer allgemeinen pflicht
und jetzt so zu tun als wenn die
opposition denen ich zustimme sei das
nicht konstruktiv wir haben ganz
konstruktiv gesagt wir brauchen diesen
im vorsorge mechanismus und jetzt auch
zusagen für den herbst also die jetzige
impfpflicht die sie fordern bringt für
diese welle gar nichts mehr für den
herbst können sie nicht definieren
inwieweit überhaupt diese impfpflicht
für alle nutzen habt wir wissen impfen
schützt ich bin auch ein befürworter des
impfens aber eben die frage des wie ist
ein ganz anderer sie sagen sie wollen
einfach mal alle durch impfen ab 18 weil
sie glauben im herbst bei irgendeiner
variante hätte das einen effekt wir
wissen aber dass wir auch unter
verfassungsrechtlichen gesichtspunkten
da sehr genau differenzieren
da stellt sich die frage ist dieses ziel
überhaupt geeignet gewissen impfstoffe
die momentan bestehen wirken viele
varianten die im herbst möglicherweise
gration gar nicht richtig wir wissen
nicht wie lange sie wirken und dann die
leute zum impfen zu verpflichten in dem
wissen dass man möglicherweise alle zwei
drei monate sich pusterla sie geben nein
nein ich habe
auf ihre äußerung her sollten wir
versuchen noch unterzukriegen dann ist
es auch fast schon neun deswegen einer
frau bei uns nochmal direkt auch dazu ja
ich meine er vermittelt ich weiß nich
noch immer nicht genau wo er persönlich
steht dabei will noch einmal deutlich
machen das was wir vorgelegt haben ist
ein interfraktioneller gruppenantrag und
kein fraktionsantrag dieser
gruppenantrag hat zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
schon über 200 unterschriften aus
unterschiedlichen fraktionen das ist die
stärke unseres vorgehens
weil wir ja ein gruppen verfahren haben
und da bedauere ich schon dass die union
im grunde nur so pauschal sich davon
abgrenzt und sich auf dieses verfahren
auch gar nicht einlässt der antrag den
sie im einbringen demnächst schließt ja
auch nicht aus dass ich tatsächlich
abgeordnete der unionsfraktion zu dem
einen oder anderen gruppenantrag
positionieren wenn es mir aufgefallen
bei der vorbereitung gibt es
überlegungen wie es geht ich glaube es
gibt einige unions-abgeordnete die sich
auf den antrag von herrn kubicki stuhr
stürzen ist übertrieben aber dabei der
java für den mit stemmen da könnte man
ja genauso gut sagen irgendwie mit dass
auch abgeordnete aus union geben die den
antrag den anderen gruppen antrag mit
unterstützen also erstens wir haben
diesen antrag den unions animalis
entwurf ich muss präziser sein wir haben
den fusionsantrag wo wir ja auch gerade
fi nieren in welche richtung das gehen
soll in der fraktion mit großer mehrheit
beschlossen dass wir sind auch insofern
eine der größten gruppen sie wollten
gruppen antragsverfahren und jetzt
werden wir sehen in den abstimmungen wie
die abstimmung läuft um letztendlich
muss man auch sagen dass die allgemeine
impfpflicht so kommt ist
unwahrscheinlich
ich muss aufhören weil die
bundestagspräsidentin an ihrem platz
angekommen ist und kino sorge hat er
unrecht war gestern getwittert einmal
hin und her und hat geschrieben
irgendwie eigentlich sollte vielleicht
doch ruhig um 38 anfang weil ich
geschrieben habe ich hab so viel zettel
und soviel stichworte auf dem zettel in
der tat wir helfen aber so einfach ist
es dann halt auch nicht vielen dank dass
sie heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind
eher sorge auch ihren frau bei uns
herzlichen dank